bonjour alexis bonjour heureuse de vous
retrouver dans la matinale de rtl france
alors que peut-on retenir de ce week-end
très politique avec pour commencer la
déclaration de candidature d'arnaud
montebourg est le premier débat de la
primaire des verts
mais alors arnaud montebourg l'avait
prévu il y avait tout un teaser à la fin
de l'été il s'est déclaré candidat à
frangy en bresse avec ce slogan
alarmante ada pour 2022 il est entré en
scène sûr que je t'aime de johnny
hallyday il se veut candidat
souverainiste à redonner à la france les
moyens
arnaud montebourg il dit dans son site
internet son mouvement l'engagement et
il est là sans doute pour essayer de
bouger un peu les lignes à gauche en
disant qu'il ne savais pas pour qui
voter alors il se présente c'est vrai
que si tous les français faisait ça on
serait avec environ 50 millions de
candidats ça ne fait pas beaucoup
avancer la machine mais voilà il tente
sa chance il a raison puisque pas de
primaires encore en vie au parti
socialiste anne hidalgo devrait l
officialiser sa candidature le week-end
prochain donc voilà une candidature qui
va permettre de faire monter les
enchères de d'agiter aussi un certain
débat d'idées à gauche même si arnaud
montebourg on se rappelle un raid a été
collègues d'emmanuel macron
illide l'a dit d'ailleurs dans son livre
témoignage s'est fait un peu berner par
le chef de l'état à l'époque où ils
étaient tous les deux à bercy au
ministère le voilà qui revient donc
après une longue pause dans les affaires
puisqu'il faisait du miel arnaud
montebourg qui revient avec un slogan
aussi qui fait débat la remonte à da
tout le monde s'est un peu posé la
question de ce que c'était et puis de
l'autre côté un premier débat
de bonne tenue entre les différents
candidats à la primaire des verts pour
parler d'idées entre sandrine rousseau
eric piolle monsieur governatori et
yannick jadot des idées là encore
d'émotion à ces diverses des appels
tendue à certains électeurs d'autres
formations et et un débat sur qu'est
l'écologie voulons-nous quelle sorte de
luth aussi sandrine rousseau qui se
défend bien sûr de vouloir faire du
clientélisme sur certaines ut voilà une
chose qui permet de montrer que les
primaires ça peut marcher parce que chez
les républicains on s'était réunis au
parc floral ce week end et la primaire
c'est quelque chose qui inquiète chez
les républicains de ne pas savoir
vraiment comment la faire avec en plus
vous en parliez la candidature encore
non officielle d'eric zemmour mais qui
se prépare à faire un tour de france on
va parler de cette candidature d'eric
zemmour on va d'ailleurs avoir un débat
politique sur la primaire des verts à
suivre le polémiste eric zemmour qui
entame donc une tournée de promotion aux
allures de campagne
tout à fait alors il sort un livre à la
croisée des chemins eric zemmour il se
met un peu en retrait d'ailleurs de sa
fonction des trialistes du figaro pour
pouvoir faire un tour de france qui a
des allures clairement de deux meetings
de campagne partout en france où il va
aller à la rencontre des français pour
défendre son livre alors c'est peut-être
simplement un coup d'édition
mais toujours est il que eric zemmour
avec ce la sortie de ce livre lance
septembre on ne sait pas encore qu'est
ce qu'il ya dedans mais il ya quand même
un peu les ce qu'ils d'un programme ou
du moins il fait ce qu'il fait
c'est-à-dire influencé il fait aussi
oublier le fait qu'il va se retrouver à
nouveau devant les juges le 8 septembre
prochain pour incitation à la haine
raciale pour les propos qu'il avait
tenus sur une chaîne à propos des
mineurs migrants isolé qui l'avait
traité de violeurs et de voleurs voilà
un moment opportun de quoi faire oublier
encore une condamnation supplémentaire
de monsieur zemmour lui va faire sa
publicité sa promotion sans doute
essayer d'engranger des soutiens pour
une potentielle candidature puisqu'il
n'est toujours pas officiellement
candidat malgré un tout toutes les
sortes de bouteilles à la mer lancés çà
et là et évidemment eric zemmour
occupait beaucoup en les conversations
des républicains ce week end au parc
floral entendre mais que peut-il faire à
notre famille politique de droite est-ce
que c'est faire du bien ou faire du mal
parce que c'est diviser davantage il est
d'abord polémiste avant d'être politique
beaucoup pensent qu'il n'a pas la
carrure d'ailleurs pour passer à la case
politique parce que c'est très différent
que d'être un agitateur d'idées plutôt
que d'être une force de proposition
politique ouais la députée de pâques à
eric ciotti a même dit qu'ils étaient
prêts à voter pour lui s'il était face à
emmanuel macron deuxième tour très
hypothétique évidemment on reste en paca
avec marseille où le chef de l'état il
était pendant trois jours quelle suite
selon vous alexis dans dans l'agenda
présidentiel vers vers 2022
alors clairement et venelles macron a
fini 1 se sont petit tour de comme à
marseille où là c'était le volet social
et écologique et le voilà qui reprend la
case des réformes il veut continuer la
réforme des retraites bien sûr il veut
aussi arrêter avec la gratuité des
billets de train pour les cheminots et
les rendre gratuit plutôt pour les
forces de police donc il veut utiliser
les 100 jours qui lui restent pour
continuer de réformer pour montrer qu'il
est là jusqu'au bout dans son mandat et
puis ils préparent bien entendu la
présidence tournante de l'union
européenne qu'il prendra à partir de
janvier avec une campagne de train de la
relance un train qui va passer partout
pour expliquer combien ces milliards
prêtés par l'union européenne ne vaut
rien nous coûter et vont permettre de
relancer l'économie française et dans
cette présidence de l'union européenne
ce sera pour lui évidemment une plate
forme programmatique le fait de se poser
à nouveau en champion de la
l'intégration et de l'union européenne
ces de janvier
jusque jusque jusqu'aux élections voilà
qui devraient aussi poser des questions
au csa sur l'utilisation de cette
présidence tournante de l'union
européenne dans la campagne qui donnera
encore plus de visibilité à aimer la con
sur des sujets qui ont fait son succès
en 2010 est donc le timing est vraiment
parfait pour lui je pense que c'est un
peu comme ça que va se faire cette fin
d'année avec sans doute un bras de fer
avec les partenaires sociaux sur les
différentes réformes qu'il veut à
nouveau mettre sous la dent sur la table
avec le risque pour lui de nouveau
quoique de la part de son gouvernement
on se rappelle un dea de la polémique
sur l'achat d'écrans plats par
l'allocation de rentrée scolaire
lancé par jean michel blanquer risque
pourrait plier
d'autres petites phrases qu'ils soient
des petits cailloux dans les chaussures
des manuels macron pour sa nouvelle
candidature pour sa réélection en 2009
22 merci beaucoup à alexis pour votre
édito ce matin une primaire des verts de
bonne tenue c'est ce que vous disiez